you have to understand
how the game of competition works one of
the best quotes i ever read about
parenting which
my uh dudley rutherford told me was the
following he says parenting fatherhood
goes through three phases
it's you first idolize oh my gosh my
dad's my hero like my sons are in the
idolizing phase right now okay
they think i'm the greatest thing since
sliced bread i'm not naive because you
know what's next phase demonization
it's demonized oh my gosh this guy's a
freaking worst father of all time
leave me the hell alone stop it i'm just
so sick and tired of this
and then you humanize so you know what
freaking hey this guy seemed right
yeah it's my pops like you know he's not
perfect i'm not perfect
you kind of go through that phase right
competition goes through the phase as
well
except the competition they first laugh
at you then they
violently oppose you then you become
self-evident right i mean it's very
simple
you cannot you can violently oppose
anybody that's coming up in
every competition this happens they
violently upon
the trey young he's not he's not the
next steph curry about 70 rookie cards
of trae young the month of the pandemic
a guy needed money because the market
took a hit he said i'm dropping 70.
i said dude i'll pay you what do you
want to do he sold me for nothing i made
4x on the money i bought 70 rookie cars
psa 10 of uh
trey trey young i said trade gotta trey
young right oh there's no way in the
world
and he has to go out there and say well
this guy's a baller he's each one and
then you hear all the comments we
always knew he was a baller you didn't
say he's a baller you said this guy's
gonna choke
but he showed up in the fourth quarter
hit the three when it was necessary even
though he's five
four four twenty two he hits that three
right you are going to go through that
phase
right now you know what you know what
status rogan has earned it's a very
unique status and that's the status
everybody fears the
competition fears and they want to
destroy
the last status you get to is saint
status
you know what saint status same saint
saints yeah of course
saints you know what saints said wrong
you're untouchable you're untouchable
rogan is saint status he's saint status
well then why spotify taking all of his
uh podcasts they can do it why is he
letting him
they can do whatever they want to do to
the guy he's saying status the only
problem with saints
here's the only problem with saints you
know it's a problem with saints they
were once sinners
so the opposition can always go and find
a bunch of dirt on them and they're
willing to pay premium to bring it out
to trash them so just wait the next two
three four five years
on strategies on tr i'm telling you
right now
rogan doesn't walk on water rogan who he
is today is because he's made mistakes
and he becomes
the person who has a lot of perspective
at his level i
guarantee you that person's made a lot
more stupid mistakes behind closers that
a lot of people don't know about then i
hope he owns it man because you know
what i don't think anybody wants
somebody perfect anymore we're in the
era of office
but but i think i think i hope he's got
such a big
loyal following yeah around him that
they're gonna come look
when it gets to a point where you know
you're a person that's like tiger pad
it's like who like tiger woods yeah but
this is different because
the difference with tiger tiger tiger
was there was an element of tiger that
i'm
10 times better than you rogan doesn't
think he's better than you yeah sure
doesn't have that energy dude i don't
know what the [ __ ] brogan says i don't
even know what i'm talking about i'm
just kind of all from grace
but for tiger tiger's like yeah um he's
20 years old doing an interview
he says what's your goal to win 19
majors to be the greatest of all time
tiger's saying this at 19 20 years old i
mean that's you know you know
that's a little bit even jordan said
look i don't know what the argument i
don't know where i'm at that's for the
critics to make the feedback but i think
i'm in the argument right now
i think if you want to make the argument
with me against magical i think i'm
finally i'm in the argument right now if
you want to involve me
so there was that element with it right
right right i think rogan is insane
status but
media's gonna find stuff yeah it's very
easy to send money and say can you tell
me something so guess what direction
they're gonna go
they can't go drugs because he openly
talks about drugs the only thing they
can go through is what
women touched women or something like
that they're gonna try to do a uh what's
that one uh comedian uh uh
uh uh yeah the one uh cavanaugh no no no
no not cavanaugh the comedian the
comedian who
was uh um we talked about him all day
louis ck
right they're gonna try to find
something yeah the thing is louie louie
did do that though i'm not saying he did
that i'm not saying he's going to
find a video of me but they waited 10
years until yeah
so just listen if it happens
don't flip and be surprised people are
gonna find out that this is a flawed man
like anybody else you don't earn saint
status being a saint
i don't think it's the audience it's
always you know the problem is it's it's
it's the company that bails
it's the people on top it's gonna have a
place that pulls that's how you have a
place
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you